Welcome students
to the Pharmacology
of the Anemias. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Here are the
learning objectives.
Please make sure you can
identify the goals of therapy
for all of these
anemias that we
will talk about
in this lecture.
Please be able to
relate the properties,
pharmacokinetic and
biochemical properties of the
supplements and of the
drugs that we'll talk about.
We will be mentioning
iron, folic acid, B12,
erythropoiesis
stimulating agents, and
hydroxyurea. You should,
of course, be able,
as always, to explain
the side effects,
potentially serious
adverse effects,
contraindications, drug
interactions, etc., Because with
this knowledge, we can
provide care to the
patient that's efficacious
with minimal adverse
effects, adverse effects
that we can mitigate.
Here are some
suggestions for learning,
practice questions.
I strongly, strongly
recommend so much so
that I put required.
Here are links if
you wish to use
them, if they
help you to learn.
Anemia is a significant
deficit in the mass of
circulating oxygen
-carrying red blood cells. I
put this little chart here
to help you recognize,
maybe you can visualize
the symptoms of anemia.
Imagine these patients,
how they must feel.
They're constantly fatigued.
Their skin is pale.
They're weak, they
feel dizzy, they may
feel shortness of
breath. They may even
have headaches and
heart palpitations.
Their hands feel
cold all the time and
feet feel cold and
their nails are brittle.
The features that we
look for when identifying
anemia and also following
when we're giving our
therapies are the hemoglobin
or the hematocrit level.
Adenemia is more than
two standard deviations
below the lower limit of
normal for age and ***.
Erythropoietin levels
are increased in direct
proportion to the
severity of the anemia.
Unless the anemia is
associated with ineffective
or ineffective
erythropoiesis, which can
be caused by a reduction
in erythropoietin
released by the kidney or
erythropoietin response,
or response to erythropoietin
would be better said.
How do we manage
the direct cause?
Key points, I just
have two slides
for you. I hope
they're helpful.
I do recommend that you
look over the PowerPoint
printout, the PDF, before
you listen to the video so
you can get some sense
of what's going on with
this lecture, of the key
points. You can understand
the backgrounds. You can
look at my charts. That's
your first pass. So, when
you get to the actual
lecture, if you wish to
listen, you don't have to if
you don't feel it's helpful,
you already have been
introduced to the ideas.
Perhaps you've developed
some questions in your
mind, and now you're going
through a second time by
listening to the lecture
and possibly getting the
answers to your questions.
That said, let's talk now
about iron deficiency anemia.
here at the top is a
structure of heme which
i will be mentioning
heme comes from animals
and here is a structure
of fe2 this is
solubilized you see
the water on here
and we'll be talking
about fe2 and also
fe3 the oxidized
form but first let's
get a little background
on physiology,
iron balance is regulated.
It's achieved by changing
intestinal absorption and
storage of iron in response
to the body's need. In other
words, if the body doesn't
need so much iron, then
less is absorbed. If it
needs more, more is absorbed.
When iron stores
are normal, we get a
small amount of the
oral dose absorbed.
When iron stores are
inadequate, we get a
larger dose absorbed
two to three times.
The relative percentage
of absorbed iron
decreases with increasing
dose. Why? I'm sure
you remember the
principle of saturation.
Saturation. The transporters
become saturated, so
the iron goes through the
intestine and out the end.
Dietary sources, the
animal iron, animal
base, that's the heme
iron, readily absorbed.
Plant-based is in the Fe3
form, the oxidized form.
It's present in leafy
greens, legumes,
nuts, seeds, dried
fruits, and any foods
that have been
fortified with iron.
So only Fe2 is absorbed.
So how do we absorb it out
of plants? Well, we eat,
and there's gastric acid
that's produced when we eat
that causes dissociation
from the food proteins, and
now that means it's soluble.
so it can be converted to
the Fe2 form. If the pH
is high, which can happen
when people are taking
certain drugs like a proton
pump inhibitor, then the
Fe3 is going to be insoluble.
It forms this complex.
Vitamin C, which as I
think we all know is in
citrus fruits, is a strong
reducing agent. So that
will be converting, reducing
Fe3 to Fe2+, readily
absorbed. Well, what
foods will inhibit the
absorption of the iron
in the plant, the plant
dietary sources? Polyphenols,
tannins are polyphenols.
These occur in coffee,
tannins of current T.
Calcium is in calcium
-rich foods like milk.
And when taken with iron,
the iron in plants, then
it can, taken with the
iron in plants or the iron
in supplements, it's going
to form these insoluble
complexes and it won't
be absorbed very well.
So let's talk about
what's happening.
Iron is absorbed by a divalent
metal transporter,
DMT1 right here,
iron 2, 2-plus form here
in the blue triangle.
It's readily absorbed
by that transporter.
And the heme carrier
protein, HCP1.
Heme iron is in this box,
Fe2 again.
it's transported in.
Once in, it's
stored as ferritin.
That's how it's represented
here. We see ferritin
storage in spleen, ferritin
storage in hepatocytes, or
it's transported out of
the cell by ferroportin FP.
And then it's carried
through the bloodstream by
transferrin. Transferrin is
indicated here without any
iron on it. Transferrin
is indicated it here with
iron on it. So it gets
transported to the bone marrow,
which is where it's used
to make red blood cells.
See it entering the bone
marrow cell, erythroid
precursor, by endocytosis.
And in here, it's
acidics. And it is released
as Fe2 and taken up
into the red blood cell,
into the hemoglobin.
It can be carried to the
liver where it's stored
or it can be exported out of
the liver by the ferroportin
and it is taken up into the
spleen by the macrophages
and stored or exported.
That's basically it.
Hepcidin is a peptide
hormone that's made in the
liver, and its function is
to regulate iron absorption.
Basically, it causes
sequestration of iron.
It regulates it that way.
Goals of therapy
To fully replace iron
balance but also to identify
and treat the underlying
cause and prevent recurrence
Oral supplementation is
certainly the preferred
method It's effective,
it's safe, it's readily
available without a
prescription, it's over
-the-counter It's inexpensive,
and we need to remind
our patients to take
it on an empty stomach
just to separate from
coffee, tea, dairy, fiber,
other foods that can
reduce its absorption.
Now, when would we
give the IV form?
Well, clearly, if the
iron is not going to
be absorbed, then it
needs to be given IV.
If it's poorly tolerated, the
person's not going to take it.
If there is severe or
ongoing blood loss,
we have to replace
that iron quickly.
If there's been a
gastric bypass or
resection, that's going
to decrease gastric
acid, and that can
reduce iron absorption.
If the person has some
sort of malabsorption
syndrome, it won't be
absorbed. If there are chronic
inflammatory diseases,
that actually increases
hepcidin, which increases
the sequestration
of iron, prevents the
absorption of iron, so to
reduce the amount of
iron that's circulating.
And if there's high
iron demand, such
as in patients who
take hemodialysis
or are receiving
erisopoedin as a drug,
well, we need to make
sure that our therapy
is working by looking
at the labs. Serum
ferritin directly
measures iron stores.
A low level is the
most sensitive and
specific test for
iron deficiency. We
certainly would want
to be monitoring that,
but not that alone.
Low hemoglobin,
hematocrit are indicative
of microcytic anemia,
which is typical of
iron, deficiency,
low MCV, mean
corpuscular volume,
low serum iron, high total
iron binding capacity.
We want to look at all
of those parameters.
I'm only asking you to
remember two products.
There are several products.
I've listed them on
the notes that come with
this lecture. If you're
curious about them,
I'm not asking you to
memorize them. They're
all equally efficacious.
Ferrosulfate is the most
common formulation of the oral.
It comes in a 325
milligram tablet that is
the ferrous and the
sulfate weight and it
releases 65 milligrams
of elemental iron. You
are not expected to
memorize these doses.
Just get the sense
that 325 milligrams
produces a certain
amount of elemental iron.
That the product is
measuring the weight
of the entire ferrous
sulfate compound
or whatever ferrous
whatever it is.
It also comes in a solution and
we see the elemental
iron there.
Generally tolerable. Most
people tolerate it quite well.
For anemia, it's given
two to four times a
day. That depends on
the severity of the
anemia and maintenance
dose is less frequent.
So iron IV, we use
iron dextran. Low
molecular weight
is commonly used.
I put this little
diamond here. I'd
like to bring your
attention down here.
High molecular weight iron
dextran was the first one
and it did cause hypersensitivity
and anaphylactoid
reactions and therefore
it's been withdrawn from the
market. The low molecular
weight is much less likely to
cause these hypersensitivity
reactions. Nonetheless,
a test dose prior to the first
dose is required
just to make sure.
The other IV iron
formulations do
not require that
first test dose.
IV infusion, many experts
prefer to give it in one
large dose, but it could
be given in two doses.
we want test dose because
of this potential for
anaphylaxis the delayed
hypersensitivity
reactions can occur in
patients who have a history
of allergies or rheumatoid
arthritis this other
hypersensitivity
well this is an
autoimmune this is
a hypersensitivity
and as you would
expect the iron
is processed by the macrophyses
Adverse effects.
Oral supplementation.
It's just mainly the
local GI irritation.
Possibly some abdominal
pain, nausea. Some
patients get constipation.
Some get diarrhea.
Remembering that all of this
iron that's being swallowed
does not get absorbed.
It just goes through. It
causes dark stools which are
harmless. But the patient
should be warned so they don't
get concerned about that.
IV, we talked about the
anaphylactoid reaction
with the high molecular
weight iron dextran. And
if a patient has in
the past received high
molecular weight iron dextran
and had a hypersensitivity
reaction, that's a
predictor that with the
low molecular weight,
they might get it as well.
And we get our infusion-related
reactions. Metallic taste,
because after all,
it is iron. The
patients are going to taste it.
And some joint
pain, muscle pains.
Watch the blood
pressure. You get
hypotension, but
it's short-lived.
May exacerbate asthma or
inflammatory arthritis,
which many recommend
premedication. The type of
premedication you can
look up if you are in the
position where you need to
be observing this patient
or administering it or
ordering the product.
Okay, drug interactions.
Well, iron can reduce
the absorption of thyroid
hormone, levothyroxine,
quinolone antibiotics like
ciprofloxacin, levofloxacin,
levodopa, and phosphate
supplements, and others.
Iron absorption itself can
be reduced by antacids,
bisphosphonates,
tetracyclines. They form that
insoluble complex so the
iron doesn't get absorbed.
That doesn't mean they can't
all be taken, it's just
that the doses should be
separated and the time
frames vary according to
whatever the drug is and
that can easily be looked
up in the drug monograph.
So let's have a
little review here.
What are the goals of
iron supplementation?
What is the first
-line therapy for iron
deficiency anemia?
What laboratory values
best reflect total
body iron stores?
What form of iron
is absorbed by the
enterocytes? And
why should oral iron
supplements be taken
on an empty stomach?
Well,
oral goals, fully replace
iron balance, treat
the underlying cause,
and prevent recurrence.
First line, oral. well.
Serum ferritin directly
measures iron stores.
Low level is most sensitive
and specific test.
And of course,
hemoglobin, hematocrit,
MCV,
serum iron,
total iron binding capacity
should be monitored
as well and it is absorbed
as fe2 heme iron and
animal foods and plants
fe3 plus which is reduced
by duodenal cytochrome
b to fe2 plus which is
then absorbed by the
transporter and why should
oral iron supplements be
taken on an empty stomach
because the polyphenols
in coffee and T, and the
calcium-rich foods and
fiber, all these things
form insoluble complexes
with the non-heme iron.
How does the body regulate the
amount of iron
that is absorbed?
Well, less iron is absorbed
when iron stores are
adequate. More iron is absorbed
when iron stores are low.
A low percentage of iron
is absorbed with higher
doses because the
transporters are saturable.
Drug interactions,
levothyroxine,
quinolones, levodopa,
others can have
lower bioavailability
because their
absorption gets reduced.
And iron itself should
not be taken together
with antacids,
bisphosphonates, or
tetracyclines, which can
reduce iron absorption.
When do we give iron IV? B,
when rapid correction is
needed, such as in bleeding,
when the oral iron is
not tolerated or is not
effective, or if their patient
is not able to absorb it.
And vitamin C is a
strong reducing agent, so
that converts Fe3 to Fe2.
And why is gastric acid
important for absorption
of iron from plant
-based foods? because the
acid releases the iron
from the proteins in the
food, making it soluble
so it's available to
be converted to Fe2+.
Moving now to folate
and B12 deficiencies.
First of all, a
little background.
Folic acid and
B12 are vitamins,
B vitamins, and coenzymes for
various metabolic functions.
Purine and thymidylate
synthesis for the
synthesis of DNA and
proteins necessary for cell
replication and
erythropoiesis in fat and
carbohydrate metabolism.
Bottom line, they're
very important coenzymes
that keep us healthy,
keep those red blood
cells forming properly.
Deficiency of either
folate or B12 decreases the
synthesis of methionine
and S-adenosylmethionine,
and I have a chart on
the biochemistry of that,
which interferes with
DNA synthesis, protein
synthesis, methylation,
and polyamines, and
results in cellular
maturation abnormalities.
large cytoplasm,
small nucleus, nuclear
maturation is delayed,
fewer RBCs, anemia,
RNA and protein
synthesis continue,
cytoplasm grows,
megaloblasts,
megaloblastic anemia.
now very important to
differentiate deficiency
of vitamin b12 but
not folate can lead to
impairment in the formation
of the myelin sheath and
that can lead to neurologic
symptoms that may
be irreversible paresthesia
in the peripheral
nerves weakness and all
of this can progress
to spasticity ataxia,
neuropsychiatric changes.
Let's talk about
folic acid first.
Here we have folic acid.
That indicates folic acid.
Folic acid in diet
is absorbed in the
duodenum and the
proximal jejunum.
Dihydrofolate is located
there and that converts it
to tetrahydrofolate which
is the active form and that
gets transported to the
liver and to tissues and it
also gets secreted into
the bile and it goes around
enteropathic circulation and
gets stored in the liver.
folate deficiency
causes a shortage of
tetrahydrofolate i
mentioned that before i
really want to drive
that point home folate
depletion takes several
months to occur now
this also i want to
drive home folate
deficiency does not
cause the characteristic
neurologic syndrome
seen in b12 deficiency
folic acid vitamin b9 is
very well absorbed can
be taken with or without
food really convenient
it's very well tolerated
parenterol is hardly ever
necessary and it's excreted
in the urine the 0.4
milligram maintenance dose
is available without a
prescription the other doses
do require a prescription.
So what's the goal
of treatment? Goal,
goal, goal, goal. For
megaloblastic anemia,
that's what we're
concentrating on, is to
reverse folate
deficiency, makes sense,
stimulate production of
healthy RBCs, of course,
and achieve complete
hematologic remission.
so the patient gets back
to their normal self.
How do we follow it?
The reticulocyte count
increases in three to
four days. That's a
pretty quick response.
Hemoglobin and hematocrit
improve in a week to two
weeks, and they become normal
in a month to two months. So
extend the treatment for
an adequate amount of time.
Avoid folic acid
monotherapy administration
in patients with
B12 deficiency.
Well, how do we know?
Laboratory testing
confirms low RBC,
low serum folate
levels, but normal B12.
That's how we know. We test.
Well, why are we doing this?
Folic acid monotherapy unmasks
vitamin B12 deficiency.
What does this mean? It
means that folic acid
will correct the anemia. It
will get that tetrahydrofolate
working, and the purines
and the thymetylate
synthesis will continue,
and that will correct the
anemia. However folate
does not correct neurologic
damage so the unmasking
part the neurologic damage
can continue to progress.
Oh it looks like the patient
is getting better the
anemia is corrected but we
have to pay attention to
neurologic damage and that's
why we test to make sure
B12 levels are normal.
Worsening neurologic
complications of B12 deficiency
may be irreversible. We
don't want to miss that.
All right. Drugs
that reduce folate
absorption in terms
of absorption and
metabolism. In
terms of absorption,
phenytoin,
sulfasalazine,
alcohol. They all
reduce the absorption.
So separate.
Separate taking them.
Metabolism, drugs that
inhibit dihydrofolate
reductase, mesotrexate,
trimethoprim,
pyrimethamine. So you
may be saying, well,
mesotrexate, I can
clearly understand.
But what about trimethoprim and
pyrimethamine? Those
are antimicrobials.
Trimesoprim is an
antibacterial and it binds with
much higher affinity to
bacterial dihydrofolate
reductase. And pyrimesamine
is an antiparasitic
and it binds with much
higher affinity to protozoal
dihydrofolate reductase.
But, that said, they
can still reduce folate
metabolism, and that
can lead to folate deficiency
with long-term use.
B12 now.
The products are
cyanocobalamin, that's here,
and it's a red liquid,
and hydroxocobalamin. This
is showing a cyanokit,
which I'll talk about.
Here's the structure.
Risk factors for B12
deficiency are a vegan or
strict vegetarian diet,
gastric or bariatric surgery.
Why? Because B12 requires
absorption by binding with
intrinsic factor. Intrinsic
factor is synthesized
by gastric cells, parietal
cells in the stomach.
And then the B12
will bind to that
intrinsic factor in
the jejunum and travel
to the distal ileum
where it's absorbed.
vitamin b12 is
stored in the liver
takes a long time to deplete
the stores three to five
years but it can happen
patients who are are not
receiving adequate b12 for
whatever reason whether it's
diet malabsorption syndromes
Lack of intrinsic factor.
Eventually, those
stores will be depleted
and the patient will
need to receive B12.
Okay, let's take a look at
this biochemical pathway.
Do physicians need to
know biochemistry? Well,
I'll let you answer that
yourself. Do you need
to understand how people
end up with megaloblastic
anemia? Do you want to
know how that happens?
I believe you are all
saying, yes, I do.
So vitamin B12 is a cofactor
in methionine synthesis.
The cofactor of methionine
synthase, sorry,
in thymidylate synthesis
and the various other
biochemical reactions.
So here we have N-methyl
tetrahydrofolate, MTHF,
which gets converted to
tetrahydrofolate with
the help of vitamin B12.
So the cobalamin
takes a hold of that
methyl, and that releases
the tetrahydrofolate.
All right, if B12 is missing,
then we don't get
this step, and the
methyl tetrahydrofolate
will accumulate.
Now, and that will
basically cause
a functional folate deficiency.
So even if a person's
getting enough
folate, it's not
being utilized.
So it gets stuck here, and
they get the megaloblastic
anemia. Now, what about
the neurologic symptoms?
Well, that's down here.
This is methylmalonyl-CoA.
This is methylmalonyl
-CoA mutase, and this is
cobalamin in this form,
deoxyadenosyl cobalamin.
So we see cobalamin
is required for
this reaction, and if
this doesn't occur,
then this substrate
will increase.
So, to recap,
without vitamin B12,
this accumulates,
doesn't turn into
tetrahydrofolate,
and we get the
megaloblastic anemia.
If B12 is missing, then we
don't get this reaction,
methylmalonyl-CoA, and also
propionyl-CoA, which is
not indicated here on this
chart, will accumulate.
Okay, so what?
Accumulation results in
production of abnormal
fatty acids that are
incorporated into neuronal
lipids and disrupt the
structure and function of the
myelin sheath. This is
about the myelin sheath.
So those are the
two mechanisms.
Folate deficiency.
And accumulation of this
leads to the myelin,
abnormal, I'll say,
abnormal myelin sheath.
you see not hard but i
know this is biochemistry
that you'd like to
understand i'm not asking
you to go through all
the entire mechanisms of
biochemistry you should
know what's going on
from a general level okay
let's talk about these
two drugs cyanocobalamin
and hydroxocobalamin
Cyanocomb almond does
come in oral tablets. It's
available over-the-counter
without a prescription. It
also comes in sublingual,
so that will bypass hepatic
metabolism. It will
bypass also any absorptive
issues in the GI tract. It
comes in a nasal solution.
IM injection is by far
the most common usage
of this drug for the
treatment of anemia.
I hesitate to call it a drug.
It's really a supplement.
Dosing a thousand
micrograms. Do I ask you to
remember it? No, but I
think you probably will.
One to two weeks. Okay, we
have to start to fill up
those B12 stores in the
liver. And then after that,
monthly maintenance.
Hydroxocobalamin, basically
the same idea for anemia.
Oh, but hydroxocobalamin
is also used for cyanide
poisoning. Look at the
difference in the dosing. This
is one milligram. This is
five grams times two doses.
Can be given IV, and if
IV is not accessible,
it can be given
intraosseously as an infusion.
Oral absorption for both
of these is variable. Well,
hydroxylcobalamin
doesn't come ******. Oral
absorption is variable from
the terminal ileum. Intrinsic
factor and calcium are
required for the transfer
of the compound across
the intestinal mucosa.
So we need intrinsic
factor to absorb B12.
Oral bioavailability of
cyanocobalamin and people with
pernicious anemia. What is
pernicious anemia? This is
an attack, an autoimmune
attack on intrinsic factor.
Okay, so intrinsic
factor is being
attacked by the immune system.
It's not functioning.
Look at the bioavailability
now in patients
with an issue. It's
basically nothing.
It's Absolutely
useless, taken ******.
IM administration makes
sense, doesn't it?
Nasal, well, the
bioavailability compared to IM
is only about 6%. Why
would we use it? Because
it's effective for
maintenance in patients with
pernicious anemia or
malabsorption. and patients
may prefer to be able
to take it intranasally
by spraying into their
nose than getting a shot,
even though that shot is
really very tolerable.
Okay, how is cyanocobalamin and
hydroxocobalamin
transferred around the body,
transported, I should say?
Transcobalamins, and these
just carry it around.
A difference here
between the two is that
hydroxycobalmin is highly
protein bound, which
means it stays in the
circulation longer,
which means there's a
longer duration, which
means the administration
is less frequent.
See how that works?
cyanocobalamin is
converted in tissues to
the active coenzyme
methylcobalamin and
deoxyadenosylcobalamin you
saw that on the biochemistry
chart the cyanide that's
what the cyano stands
for a cyanide is just a little
piece of cyanide in there
is metabolized in the liver
to non-toxic thiocyanate.
The body is very able to
detoxify that cyanide.
Hydroxycobalamin doesn't have
any cyanide in
it. It's hydroxy.
And it's also converted to
the useful forms of B12.
goes out through urine
and feces it is undergoes
enteropatic circulation
thiocyanate is excreted in the
urine and this also excreted
in the urine okay storage
90% stored in the liver as
active coenzyme and it's
also stored in other
tissues so let's check our
knowledge on these two
B vitamins, what vitamin
deficiencies lead to megaloblastic
anemia, how do mechanisms
of anemia by the two vitamins
differ, which vitamin
deficiency leads to
neurologic symptoms, and why.
Okay, folate and B12. I know
you answered that immediately.
How do the mechanisms of anemia
by the two vitamins differ?
Folic acid deficiency
leads to diminished
tetrahydrofolate, and therefore,
it's not available for the
methyl transfers needed
for the synthesis of
thymitylate and purines
essential for DNA replication
during cell division, and
therefore, it stalls cell
division in the erythroid
precursors. B12 deficiency
traps folate as unusable
methylfolate, which stops
production of the thymethylate
and purines needed
for RBC synthesis.
dysfunctional folate deficiency.
And I know you know that it's
B12 deficiency that causes
dysfunction of methylmalonyl
-CoA mutase, leading to
accumulation of methylmalonyl
-CoA and also propionyl
-CoA, which can cause production
of abnormal fatty acids
that are incorporated into
the neuronal lipids and
disrupt the structure and
function of the myelin sheath.
And that's going to result
in neurologic symptoms.
Parasthesia,
weakness, spasticity,
ataxia, and
neuropsychiatric changes.
And finally, how
does absorption of
folic acid and
vitamin B12 differ?
Well, folic acid is taken up
early in the small intestine.
The duodenum and proximal
jejunum, it meets
the dihydrofolate
reductase in there.
It's converted to
tetrahydrofolate and it
is transported to the
liver and tissues.
B12, however, complexes
with intrinsic
factor and is
absorbed through the
terminal ileum and
stored in the liver.
And I put the
details here for you.
It's all at the end
of this lecture.
let's talk about the
erythropoiesis stimulating
agents which of course
has an acronym epa's
we'll only talk about
erythropoietin alpha it is
the first one that was
developed we have another
couple available in the
united states and the
only difference is they
have a longer duration
Epoetin alpha is human
erythropoetin. It's a recombinant
version. And there are
biosimilars available also.
I put the erythropoetin
and darbopoetin here so
you can compare the
pharmacokinetics if you wish.
It is only the epoetin
alpha you need to remember.
They are given IV, I'm
just going to go down,
epoetin. It's given
IV or subcutaneously.
Now the subcutaneous version,
I'm going to go
right here to explain
why the bioavailability
is so low.
These are large molecules,
and they will be,
this is the sub-Q version.
the large molecules diffuse
into the lymphatics and
this is a slow process and
its capacity limited and in
the interstitial spaces are
proteases peptases peptidases
which degraded macrophages
which eat it up the
manufacturer is dosed it
through clinical trials so that
it It achieves adequate
bioavailability when given
subcutaneously and
inappropriately selected patients.
Erythropoietin is administered
three times weekly,
and it's not significantly
removed by dialysis.
Now we can compare
this three times weekly
compared to once every
two weeks, and it's going
to depend on various
features, but you can see
there's a difference in
the frequency of dosing.
Erysopoetin, which is
what this is, concentrates
in the liver, bone, marrow,
and kidneys just like
natural erysopoetin.
Half-life in adults,
subcutaneous has a good
long half-life, which would
explain the three times
weekly, and that's going
to be variable depending
on the patient itself.
degradation of the drug
and so on. It is used
for chronic kidney
disease. We give it IV
here and we see that
the half-life varies but
not a great deal between
adults and children.
Much longer half-life
with darbopoietin alpha.
What about effect.
Hemoglobin and hematocrit
increase in two to
six weeks after initiating
treatment. It takes
a while to get that
RBC production going.
And this is just a little
chart here to help you
kind of visualize what's
going on. This is a kidney.
this is low oxygen,
which will stimulate
erythropoietin formation
synthesis in the kidney,
which will then move on
to the bone marrow, make
red blood cells. And
when there's enough red
blood cells, enough oxygen,
that will be a negative
feedback on erythropoietin
synthesis. this.
Now, in chronic
kidney disease, that
erythropoietin is
not being made. And
that's why these
ESAs are recommended.
Physiology, I
just explained it.
Pharmacology. Like natural
erythropoietin, these drugs,
epoetin alpha, bind to the
erythropoietin receptor.
It's not stimulating
erythropoietin, natural
erythropoietin synthesis.
It's just binding to the
receptors because it is,
after all, erythropoietin.
The receptors dimerize
and activate the JAK
-STAT signaling pathway,
which will activate
the PI3, AKT, and
MAP, and so on, and
then we get our red
blood cell production.
It increases survival
and proliferation of
the erythroid precursors
by reducing apoptosis
of the progenitor cells,
increasing maturation
into reticulocytes,
and increasing RBC
production, just like
natural erythropoietin.
Goals of therapy.
Well, we talked
about the iron and B
vitamins, the goals
of therapy were to
replete the stores.
That's different here.
The goal is to reduce the
need for RBC transfusions by
increasing hemoglobin
to the lowest level that
alleviates anemia while
minimizing thrombotic
and cardiovascular
risk. Okay, we're not
talking about a goal being
to increase hematocrit into
the so-called normal range
for the population that's
being treated. It's merely
to reduce the need for red
blood cell transfusions.
These drugs do increase
blood viscosity, and that's
going to increase thrombotic
and cardiovascular risk.
You see how to think about
the goal with ESA therapy?
So what do we use it
for? Anemia of chronic
kidney disease,
symptomatic myelodysplastic
syndrome, and chemotherapy
-induced anemia in
selected patients. This
isn't for everybody.
and chronic kidney
disease is the most common
reason and here's why we're
careful in chemotherapy
induced anemia they've
been shown to increase
serious risks especially
thromboembolism and
worse cancer outcomes
without improving survival.
So the basic idea
here is to reduce
the need for
transfusion in this
chemotherapy-induced
anemia. That's it.
Monitoring, well, hemoglobin,
of course you figure
that, once weekly until
maintenance dose is
established, then we keep
watching once monthly.
We're making red blood
cells, so we have to be
watching those iron
stores, and we give iron
to make sure the red blood
cells have enough iron
when they're being
synthesized. Have to watch
the blood pressure.
We're increasing blood
viscosity. What do you
think is going to happen?
Increase blood pressure.
For seizures, well, what are we
thinking about with seizures.
First few months,
increased blood viscosity
and rapid changes in
blood pressure can cause
seizures, but fortunately
they're uncommon.
And of course in kidney
disease, we'll do what
we always do, watching
the serum chemistry,
the fluid balance,
etc. And of course we
watch for those neurologic
symptoms. Oh, sorry,
wrong button.
Adverse effects.
Well, we haven't seen
particularly serious adverse
effects with anything up
till now, but now we do.
U.S. boxed warning. I
don't think I needed
to put that in red
if it says U.S. boxed
warning, but I will put
a red line around it.
ESAs increase the
risk of death,
myocardial infarction, ******,
venous thromboembolism,
and incidentally, thrombosis
of vascular access.
Hypertension, cardiovascular
events, I mentioned
those before,
some rash Stevens
-Johnson syndrome can
occur. We are introducing
this protein. Yes,
it's a recombinant human
protein, but people
can develop a
hypersensitivity reaction.
Well, we're not going to
full hemoglobin levels.
We're going to the
minimum point at which the
anemia is relieved, and
we can avoid transfusion,
which is 11 or below. We
don't want to go above 11.
CKD patients are at greatest
risk for cardiovascular
adverse events, and
so is everybody else.
pure red cell aplasia
doesn't happen very often but
it's something to not ignore
what happens is development
of neutralizing
antibodies against the
erythropoietin and that can
lead to pure red cell aplasia.
It's seen in CKD patients
receiving the sub-Q.
That's it.
Chemotherapy, just
what I said before.
Contraindications. Well,
you can predict the
contraindications by knowing
what the adverse effects are.
Uncontrolled
hypertension. Severe red
cell aplasia that
begins after treatment.
History of hypersensitivity
reactions and we don't
use more than, I mean
we don't use different
erythropoiesis stimulating
agents together. Just pick one.
So let's check our
knowledge. What is the
main source of
erythropoietin in adults?
Specialized paratubular
interstitial cells of
the kidney. They're called
fibroblast-like cells.
And the erythropoietin is
stimulated to be synthesized
with low oxygen levels,
hypoxia, anemia. What is
the bioavailability of
subcutaneous? Why is it so low?
Because ESAs are large
molecules that slowly
diffuse into lymphatics,
which are capacity limited.
And there are proteases,
peptidases, macrophages
in the interstitial
space. And that's going to
reduce the amount that
gets to the central system.
How do ESAs stimulate
erythropoiesis?
Well, they bind directly to
the receptor on erythroid
progenitor cells in bone
marrow. And then those
receptors dimerize, JAK
-STAT pathway, and so on.
They do not stimulate
the release of
erythropoietin from,
and I didn't finish. I
guess I wanted you to
finish it yourselves.
What is the effect
of activating
the signaling pathway?
Increased survival
and proliferation
of erythroid precursors.
Reduced apoptosis, increased
maturation,
increased production.
What is the primary
clinical goal?
To safely, safely
reduce the need for
transfusions of red
blood cells by using the
lowest dose needed to
alleviate the anemia.
Clinical condition
is most frequently,
is it most frequently used, and
that is the anemia
of chronic disease.
and I explained why here.
What laboratory parameter
is used to guide
EPA dose adjustments?
And that, of course, is
the hemoglobin or
hematocrit concentration.
What is the major
mechanism-related adverse
effect? And that is
thrombosis. That can
lead to myocardial
infarction and ******.
And that occurs because of
the increased viscosity.
Which brings us to our
last product, hydroxyurea
for sickle cell anemia.
This is the first-line
therapy. It is the only
one I have a star on.
I put the structure here
on the right-hand side,
and I'm showing you a
picture of the pills.
Chrysalisumab and L
-glutamine are alternates, and
they can also be used
together with the hydroxyurea.
they are intended to be
started when the individual
is well it is not for
treating acute pain
oral well absorbed high
protein binding widely
distributed to the
brain concentrates on
leukocytes and erythrocytes
well that's good
we want it to concentrate
in erythrocytes
it's metabolized in
the liver also by
intestinal bacteria
great bioavailability
oops sorry and around
40 percent of the dose
is excreted in the
urine as is and this
is measured in sickle
cell anemia patients.
The effect is induction
of HBF, fetal hemoglobin.
And we see it takes about
a month to three months
for that to occur, for
that hemoglobin to get up.
Okay, the goal of
therapy, to reduce
sickling by increasing
fetal hemoglobin,
which will improve
red cell physiology.
Increasing HBF inhibits
hemoglobin S polymerization,
and it's that hemoglobin
S that is the wrong
type of hemoglobin in
these patients with this
genetic disease. That
type of hemoglobin will
polymerize when the oxygen
is off. and that's what
causes the sickling. So
if we can increase the
HBF, that's going to
inhibit this HBS problem.
And therefore, that will
reduce the acute effects,
vasoocclusion, hemolysis,
and disease complications.
Now, what about
hydroxyurea? Well, this is
something called an
RNR inhibitor And I'll
talk more about that
on the next slide.
Crizalizumab is a P-selectin
inhibitor, which means
it's going to reduce the
adhesion of these inflammatory
mediators and therefore
reduce the vasoocclusion.
And L-glutamine, this is
pharmaceutical grade, it's
not just something off the
shelf, will will reduce
oxidative stress by improving
this NADH, *** plus balance.
All right, hydroxyurea.
Here we have our
ribonucleotide reductase.
ribonucleotides.
Ribonucleotide reductase
forms deoxyribonucleotides,
which are used
in DNA synthesis,
and this is what's
being inhibited. Okay,
what's that got to do
with sickle cell anemia?
Biochemistry. First of all, we
have to figure out
what's going on.
And I mentioned
the DNA synthesis.
Stress erythropoiesis.
Oh, okay, what is that?
Hydroxyurea binds iron
molecules in the catalytic
subunit of R and R. Of course,
we know that. That slows
the DNA synthesis in rapidly
dividing red blood cells,
of course it does, and
that will induce mild bone
marrow suppression. That's
called stress erythropoiesis.
And therefore, the bone
marrow shifts toward
production of new
immature red blood cells,
which are called stress
erythroid precursors,
that preferentially
express the gamma globin
that is needed for fetal
hemoglobin production.
So, by inhibiting
ribonucleotide reductase, that's
going to induce the mild
bone marrow suppression, and
that's going to shift
production to new immature RBCs
that preferentially express
gamma globulin genes.
There you go.
Well, that's not all.
Hydroxyurea is converted
to nitric oxide,
and that will stimulate soluble
guanyl cyclase,
increasing cyclic GMP,
and that, in turn,
will enhance gamma
globulin gene
transcription for more HPF.
So, all of these
features contribute
to its reduction of
the vaso-occlusion.
Hydroxyurea-induced mild
bone marrow suppression
lowers neutrophils,
platelets, adhesion molecules,
decreases inflammatory
cell adhesion molecule
interactions, and
microvascular plugging.
Vaso-occlusive pain
crises are reduced.
this is just a picture to
show you what I just said
and it lists out the various
beneficial effects of
the hydroxyurea adverse
effects well you can imagine
it's working in the it's
it's reducing the conversion
of ribonucleotides to
deoxyribonucleotides and
rapidly proliferating cells
as in the bone marrow.
So neutropenia, anemia,
thrombocytopenia.
But that said,
hydroxyurea is pretty
well tolerated over
the long term in sickle
cell patients. And
that's just a matter
of paying attention.
Frequent monitoring of
CBC with differential,
especially during drug
initiation and dose
titration watch it adjust
the dose as necessary
all right what else well
GI disturbances that
happens with so many
oral drugs can cause some
skin reactions causes
hyperpigmentation so the
darkening of the skin
and nails and it can
cause some hair loss.
Patients need to be informed
about it. These obviously
are not serious,
but patients care. And
if patients care, I care.
Reproduction now. All
right. We don't want to be
inhibiting DNA synthesis
in the growing fetus.
Teratogenic and animal
reproduction studies
may cause fetal harm,
may damage spermatozoa
and testicular tissue, causing
azoospermia and oligospermia.
That's in people.
Males and females of
reproductive potentials
should use effective
contraception during and for
at least six months to one
year following therapy.
And it's not recommended
for nursing mothers.
all right let's check our
knowledge what clinical
complications of sickle
cell disease are reduced
by hydroxyurea therapy
vaso-occlusive pain
crisis and acute chest
syndrome which is life
-threatening and it's related
to the vaso-occlusion what
is the goal of hydroxyurea
therapy, and sickle
cell anemia to reduce
sickling by increasing fetal
hemoglobin and improving
red cell physiology.
How does this work?
HBF reduces polymerization
of the aberrant
form, HBS, which
is the root cause
of sickling and vaso
-occlusive crisis.
and the principal mechanisms
stress erysipoesis
hydroxyurea binds iron
molecules in the catalytic rnr
slows dna synthesis and
rapidly dividing rbcs
leading to mild bone marrow
suppression and therefore
the bone marrow shifts
toward production of the
new immature rbcs the
stress erythroid precursors,
and that will preferentially
express gamma globin
genes, thereby increasing
hemoglobin F production.
And secondary mechanisms,
nitric oxide production
stimulates soluble guanyl
cyclase, increases cyclic
GMP concentrations, which
in turn enhance gamma
globin gene transcription,
more hemoglobin f and
mild bone marrow suppression
lowers neutrophils
platelets and adhesion
molecules which decreases
inflammatory cell adhesion
molecule interactions and
microvascular plugging
major dose limiting toxicity
bone marrow suppression
especially neutropenia as
with a lot of chemotherapies
cosmetic effects
hyperpigmentation can cause
darkening of skin and nails.
Laboratory tests to monitor.
CBC was differential.
And long-term
hydroxyurea therapy
in sickle cells, is it safe?
Yes, but you have to monitor.
I put a chart here to
kind of put the whole
thing together for you.
If it helps, great.
And the summary I'm not
going to go over. I hope
that it's put here for
you in an easy to digest
way and here are the
answers to the questions.
Lots of questions.
Hopefully these
help you review and
that concludes the
lecture on the
treatment of anemias.